ma tin 0 c'est à vous oui bonjour roger
karoutchi
vous faites partie des soutiens de
nicolas sarkozy pour la primaire vous le
pousser à se déclarer rapidement
candidat alors que lui souhaiter
attendre l'été vous avez des jeunes et
je crois avec lui mardi
est-ce que vous allez réussir à le
convaincre sur sa candidature sur le
calendrier il est lui le président de la
famille politique est bon il ya eu les
élections régionales les élections
internes du parti au mois de janvier
franchement le climat à l'intérieur du
parti est tel que il peut dire qu'il a
permis l'apaisement après les divisions
du passé
il ne souhaite pas entrer trop vite dans
le débat des primaires c'est au mois de
novembre
les français sont pas dessus c'est pour
ça que quand je mets les autres sont
déjà dessus
abbas a eu non pas la responsabilité la
famille politique
donc ils peuvent aller et venir doute
sur la candidature nicolas d'or mais
plus de doute sur la candidature
allez moi j'appelle à cette candidature
et et sincèrement je le dis comme ça je
n'ai pas été le mieux traité du
quinquennat précédent 1 il y en a qui
ont été ministres beaucoup plus
longtemps que moi est mieux traité que
moi et qui aujourd'hui ne trouve que des
défauts quinquennat précédent
moi j'ai toujours considéré comme à
jeudi j'allais dire j'ai quitté le
ministère non vous fait quitter le mr
houle quittez pas de vous-mêmes sauf
drame
bon quand on m'a fait quitter le mystère
vous n'avez entendu de ma part aucun mot
désagréable parce que c'était un honneur
d'être ministre mais c'est pas un dû et
c'est pas une propriété vous ne l'êtes
plus vous ne l'est plus points ça ne
change pas mes opinions sur le fait que
j'ai beaucoup d'estimé pour tous les
candidats et pour tous les responsables
avec qui je suis en bons termes
parce que ce sont des hommes d'état et
des hommes publics compétents mais en
même temps nous sommes dans une période
de crise
moi je crains je le dis franchement que
2016 2017 et l'aggravation de la crise
financière de la crise économie de la
crise du terrorisme de la crise
sécuritaire et je sais que dans ces
situations là il n'y a pas seulement la
qualité d'homme d'état qui va jouer il
ya la force
il ya la pugnacité il ya la volonté et
moi j'ai vu comment nicolas a fait en
2008 quand il ya eu la crise financière
que les banques s'écroulent et que
l'économie
les économies des français allaient
disparaître je les ai vus me dire à moi
bill chargé des relations avec le
parlement il me faut un accord du
parlement avant d'aller en allemagne
négocier je le veux en quatre jours je
lui dis c'est impossible c'est
inconstitutionnel
on a réuni tous les présidents de
groupes de gauche et de droite à
l'elysée et nicolas sarkozy a obtenu
qu'au moins chacun d'entre eux
s'engagent à ne pas faire de recours
devant le conseil constitutionnel
jamais vu jamais vu qui peut faire ça
pour sauver le pays qui peut voilà c'est
tout alors après les autres tout le
monde est très bien j'aime tout le monde
toujours un débat de la primaire qui
s'annonce quand même assez rude pendant
la campagne va être publiée à
destination des candidats
si vous deviez le rédiger quel en serait
le premier prof le premier principe il
est clair pour tout le monde
nous appartenons à la même famille
politique presque tous ceux qui sont
déjà engagés dans cette primaire ont
appartenu au même gouvernement
alors on peut défendre ses convictions
défendre des idées un peu différente
pour autant c'est pas la peine de
petites phrases c'est pas la peine de
mots aigres-doux parce qu'au lendemain
de la primaire faudra tous se rassembler
pour assurer l'alternance en 2017 et
gagné contre la gauche voilà vous étiez
avec les militants des hauts de seine
mercredi soir et pour une consultation
sur le projet du parti
vous les avaient incités à faire des
propositions fortes oui et je vous cite
a pas secouer le cocotier
alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire est ce
que vous trouvez que les responsables
politiques de droite sont trop frileux
sur le plan des idées pourquoi de droite
les responsables politiques en général
moi le premier parce que enfin sortez
dans la rue on va on va se prendre des
coups sur la tête afin pas que nous
avons aussi les journalistes mais tout
le monde est discréditée c'est les gens
sont exaspérés les gens ne croient plus
dans la vie publique
il faut donc des propositions fortes
pour changer le système pour changer les
propositions pour rendre l'action
crédible pour faire en sorte que celui
qui sera élu président la république en
100 jours
change tout parce que les gens n'y
croient plus donc oui il faut faire des
propositions et c'est pas une question
d'âge un j'entends des commentaires en
tout genre pour les candidats à la
présidentielle n'est pas une question
d'âge
une question d'état d'esprit qui veut
changer le pays qui veut faire en fait
en 2017 en 1958 moi je suis pour
allons-y alors avec mathilde on va vous
interrogé aussi sur sa cette interview
donnée au magazine elle du président l'a
permis à l'occasion de l'ag lui qui
déteste et mini c'est toujours social
rebaptisé le ministère de la famille oui
il veut le rebaptiser en ministère des
femmes avaient vu ce matin la manif pour
tous en être signés ainsi que hervé
mariton député de la drôme des
républicains pour vous cela ce pluriel
et le signifie quoi qu'est ce que ça
change je ne sais pas enfin 6 de la
symbolique pour faire plaisir moi je
n'ai pas voté la loi taubira je n'ai pas
voté contre je me suis abstenu je suis
plutôt favorable à l'article 1
un peu hésitant pour ne pas dire très
hésitant sur les articles sur
l'affiliation à l'adoption donc je me
suis abstenu
mais sincèrement la famille on peut la
considérer comme on veut que ça veut
dire de passer de la famille à l'efa
bailly feriel ça veut rien dire
alors que la femme soit monoparentale
homoparentale terrassé la famille moi je
suis pour une politique familiale je
supporte pas le fait de fiscaliser les
allocations familiales ou de les baisser
je ne supporte pas le fait de baisser le
quotient familial c'était une force de
notre pays
la république et au pluriel ça vous
plaît non moi je pense qu'on aurait pu
rester un ministère de la famille et
qu'à l'intérieur on pouvait intégrer
toutes les familles fait je vois pas
sincèrement c'est du jeu j'ai entendu
laurence rossignol que je respecte
d'autant qu'elle était sénatrice mais
que je respecte mais franchement
l'explication ne tient pas la route
merci merci à garowe si c'est le mot de
la fin on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine même lieu même heure merci
mathilde merveille